[Music]
let's go to
giselle in new orleans is it gisele
yeah you said it right how are you dr
john yes i was about to say gazelle but
i said gizelle and i like it i get that
all the time beautiful beautiful name so
what's going on how can i help
hi um so
yeah i guess my question is sorry i'm a
little nervous too oh dude i'm super
nervous
you've heard that i'm not very good at
this and giselle is a wonderful name so
i'm i'm out on the thin ice here you're
good
um yeah i guess my question is um
i
have really been struggling
with um people pleasing for
as long as i can remember i'm sorry i'm
choking up a little bit no it's okay
it's okay
tell me about it
yeah um
man it's just it's just hard to even
know um
who i am sometimes because i feel like
depending on who i'm talking to or
people in my life i'm just trying to be
who they want me to be or
not not upset them or hurt them or be a
burden so
um
yeah it's just been a real struggle um
with people pleasing and not really
knowing who i am
in the process because i'm trying to be
who everyone else wants me to be or not
hurt people or be a burden to them i
don't i don't know if that's making
sense oh big hey big time
and
like it breaks my heart who told you
this
who who modeled this for you that this
was the way you needed to go through
life
um
i guess for as long as i could remember
it never felt safe to be vulnerable or
share
how i felt was that mom or dad or both
or a brother or sister where'd that come
from
um
[Applause]
i i hate to put it on my parents i would
i would say my mom if i'm being honest
yeah
and uh
yeah just it just sucks
um
i'm struggling in relationships with
friendships and
and i get all the time people saying
giselle you're way too nice you you
don't speak up you don't say what's on
your mind and i just feel paralyzed yeah
um
somewhere so i want to free you from
something okay
i bet you and i could sit down over a
cup of coffee and you could tell me some
stuff about your childhood that would
haunt me is that true
um not not from a traumatic uh like
abuse kind of thing
but some things that your mom said that
are still firmly planted in your soul
yeah
and
was your dad in the picture too
um yes and no like they had a great
marriage and their great parents i think
it just felt very emotionally absent
there so here's here's what i want you
to hear me say
trauma is acute and i know that you're
like whoa whoa it's not trauma
when moms lodge
personality issues into you or when you
are responsible for making sure mom is
happy or not angry or not exhausted or
not tired or not stressed
that is a weight
that a child is not strong enough to
carry
and when there is another parent figure
in the home who doesn't reach over to
help
that's trauma too
traumas both the things that were done
to you and the things that should have
happened that weren't that didn't happen
hear what i'm saying
yeah i i hear what you're saying and i
in no way want to just sit here and bash
on your parents i don't know their life
i don't know what's going on
but what i want you to do is this i want
you to draw the string from where did
where did my body learn
to to cycle down
because now that you're how old are you
now
uh 28 okay you're 28
and the way it comes out now the advice
you get the
pinterest and instagram scrolling that
we do now tells you
you just need to fill in the blank
and it turns into a character issue or a
moral issue or a strength like you're
weak or you're not strong enough why are
you not letting just standing up
and what i want you to hear me say is
your body's acting on your behalf
your body recognizes that when somebody
throws out a strongly worded sentence
and you object to it you better be quiet
because it's safe here in the silence
or when a guy starts putting you in a
situation that you're not comfortable
with
go along for the ride it's just better
for everybody
just don't say anything
or when your boss says something and
you're like what well that's not even my
fault would it
just it's gonna be fine just right am i
on to something
yeah i just
like i definitely agree it's either
paralysis or it feels like well if i
just
lie to avoid this conflict or
to tell the person what they want to
hear then i'll be okay that's right even
if it's not
the truth and so if you take your
like the alarms going off in your body
and sometimes we call those emotions or
feelings whatever you want to call
when you take those and you just squash
them if you think about compressing them
down another word of compression is to
depress
right
yeah is to push down
and so many people walk through their
lives
with everything compressed into a tiny
nuclear reactor that just sits in their
soul and it eats them from the inside
out
absolutely
so if no one's ever told you this before
you are worth laughing at things you
think are funny
you're worth having your own opinions
especially when everyone disagrees with
you
you're probably really really smart
because you've got to watch a lot of
loud-mouthed idiots in your day without
trying to compete
you probably have a
i would say world-class probably
borderline superhero ability to read
people's energy because you've had to to
stay safe
yeah you know when a punch is coming you
know when a threat is on your way
and you also know like the matrix how to
get out of the way of that thing or how
to just take it and keep going
and i want you to know that those
qualities can also make you
an extraordinary leader
a powerful person who speaks when they
want to when they decide it's necessary
and that when they do speak everybody
listens
you can be in dating relationships and
romantic relationships where your needs
are met all of them
and where you have permission to meet
other people's needs
you're worth all of that okay
how do you want to move forward
um
i guess that's why i'm
calling too because i just i feel like
now i'm
either more aware of it or i've just
gotten to the point where i'm exhausted
and
i'm ready to i'm just ready to make
changes and awesome
yeah okay so
two words that you've mentioned today
are giant red flags for me can i poke on
them for a minute
yeah okay
you are not
have never been
and will never be a burden
never say that word again
fair
fair
i'll say it again
you are not have not and will never be a
burden
you're my new sister and my new friend
and that word leaves your vocabulary you
may be uncomfortable you may be
surrounded by weirdos
you may be in a room of people who don't
like seinfeld you're the only one with a
sense of humor and clearly superior
intelligence
but you're never a burden
do you believe me right
i believe you
kids who grow up with moms who just
swipe
their phones all day and ignore them
kids who grow up with moms who yell and
scream a lot
or say oh honey don't wear that shirt we
don't look pretty in that like that kind
of stuff
kids who grow up with dads who don't
hold them tightly and say i love you i
love you i love you
the alternative is they feel like there
must be something wrong with me
because my dad won't even hug my dad
won't even tell me he loves me my dad
won't even fight for me my mom won't
even look at me my mom gets mad and she
ghosts me she turns silent on me
and i'm only eight what did i do that
was so bad that this adult who i'm
supposed to love won't even talk to me
right so all those things translate to
25 years down the road 20 years down the
road
this room would be better if i just
wasn't here
and that's not true
okay
okay
the second thing is the exhaustion you
feel is a almost 30 year old woman whose
body has been fighting and running and
freezing year after year after year for
way too long
your body's been on on
full tilt
for decades now
and this is the season when
you start taking one more drink and one
more drink
or you hook up with one more person
or you
eat one more this is me looking in the
mirror bag of candy or donut or whatever
or you get on a treadmill and you run
one more mile or you work 10 more hours
this week and then 10 more hours next
week at work this is when our bodies
start to say dude i can't keep doing
this and so we start looking for duct
tape to put over the alarms
am i on onto something
yeah or the new drug the new 21st
century drug is netflix i'm just going
to go home and get under the covers
yeah right
so here's where we go from here number
one this is gonna be a cheesy answer and
i hope it doesn't sound like a ball of
cheese but i want you to hang on the
line and i'm gonna send you a copy of my
new book it's called own your past
change your future it's like you just
threw this one to me on an underhand
softball pitch okay it's gonna walk you
through it
the path here is this
you have to own the stories and i know
you love your mom i know you love your
dad and you love your siblings and your
high school boyfriend whatever you gotta
own those stories
only when you own them does your brain
go okay she now knows
where the bears are
and then you gotta acknowledge reality
here's where i'm at i'm 28 years old i'm
beautiful i'm actually pretty dang smart
i'm kind
i think i'm funny and i've got a good
sense of humor and i do like power
ranger movies i don't care what people
say about like whatever whatever the
thing is right
you gotta own reality and then you have
to be about the hard stuff
which is i got to grieve what i should
have had that i don't have
i have to
begin to work hard on changing my
actions and work hard on changing my
thoughts what does that look like in
reality
super hard yet super simple
it is when the moment you think oh i
just need to be quiet you say
inside your head nope i'm just gonna
speak out just because i'm practicing
and then you raise your hand or you just
speak out because all the other idiot
dudes in the room are speaking it like
no bro i don't like that you go nope i
actually do like that i like the colors
on that font i like the marketing angle
here and as the only woman in this room
i think women would buy this and then
you inside you go the voices will go
what are you doing no
right
they already are okay just yeah just
practicing that and here's what i want
you to do i want you to feel that
don't run from it go right in the middle
of it
and let your body know we're okay
and if these idiots fire me for speaking
up they suck and i don't want to work
here anyway
but they probably won't
they i'm a loudmouth idiot and i try to
be inclusive but i just get all fired
i love it when people in my who are on
my team
who normally are quiet speak up
because they're usually right
okay
and i want you to practice this and i
want you to feel it in your body
the big thing here is when your body
takes off on you when your heart starts
beating when you're when you start to
shrink back
have a next thing in line
nope
i'm not going to back up here
nope i don't want to kiss you i'm just
going to tell you that's not happening
tonight thank you though
don't worry i'll pay for my half of
dinner tonight whatever that looks like
for you mom nope i'm not coming home for
thanksgiving this year i'm gonna stay
with my friends
because i'm almost 30 and i can do
whatever i want to are you you see what
i'm saying
yeah i definitely see what you're saying
so do you have a friend
do you have somebody in your life that
you can begin to discuss some of this
with
probably some of it for the first time
ever
yeah the second part
yeah so you've heard me say this on the
show a million times i'll say it more
time
grief demands a witness
you have to say some of these things out
loud
you know my mom told me one time
can you believe my dad didn't
you have to say those things out loud
that's how we bring our mind back online
oh she here she acknowledges this okay
cool
bear threat averted now we will stop
responding as though everything's on
fire
and you're gonna have to train your body
over time to be less anxious
and to be less exhausted
and give it the
it needs
but if you will keep taking these tiny
little steps keep practicing towards
becoming the person that you're aiming
towards
i promise you you will become it you
know how i know because i did
because my wife did because my friends
around me have
okay
okay so i'm down the road from you
and i'm looking on the other side and
i'm telling you there's a light over
there if you'll work hard for the next
couple of years and working hard just
means practicing this new way of being
and you're gonna fall
you're gonna i've been in meetings here
then i didn't speak up
and i drove home so pissed at myself
and i told somebody or two people and
then i got back into the next day
you're gonna do that it's gonna be part
of your journey and then you're gonna
just find yourself
with an ability to shoulder and carry
things that you never knew you had
because somebody took that from you and
you were very very young
so do you feel ready to rock and roll or
what
yeah
it's definitely scary um yes so scary
i'm ready
you
are worth it
you believe me
i do
you don't so i'ma say it again
you're worth it
you are not
will never be
have never been a burden
you my new friend gizelle
are worth it
you're worth it you're worth it you're
worth it you're worth it
and everybody listening to this
you're worth it